function for these purposes well first
of all let me just say I do appreciate
it is the salt deduction is having
impact on some of the economies and we
are monitoring that carefully we did
allow for a deduction that did cover a
very significant amount of the people as
it relates to the charile deduction this
administration very much supports
charitable deductions as does the
department I think the issue that you're
referring to is that there are no limits
on charitable deductions where there are
not a quid pro quo attached the question
I think you're referring to is where
certain states tried to get around the
federal law by passing certain laws and
I understand that's still under further
review by the IRS and our legal
department but well what about the 33 oh
there's the 31st state said I've been
using this for decades now should they
have to stop immediately well again we
spent a lot of time on this guidance we
are trying to make sure that the
legitimate use of tax credits is still
allowed I believe with the guidance is
still under review and we're happy to
follow up with your office do you have a
sense of timing of when we're gonna have
when those rules will go final I think
it's gonna it's gonna be out shortly
it's it is a priority of ours again we
want we want to make sure that
legitimate use of charitable
contributions is support it I know you
were very involved personally which a
little unusual in the approval process
of these guidelines why did you feel
need to get personally involved in these
particular ones I know some most you
don't right actually that's not the case
we meet almost daily with a team at
Treasury Office of Tax Policy general
counsel all of our areas and we review
actually every single regulation I I
think it's my obligation given the
complexities issues to make sure that
I'm briefed on them so this this session
was no different than others thank you
unsolved for a second you advocated for
solid cuts by saying they quote
predominantly benefited high-income
earners to help pay for major tax cuts
for American families an estimated that
quote approximately five percent of
taxpayers
well itemize and have state-level income
tax deductions above the saw cap in in
my state in New Jersey forty two point
seven
five not five percent of taxpayers in
the fifth District or approximately 350
nine thousand people in the four
counties I represent actually claimed a
salt deduction that's far from five
percent in fact the average in in Bergen
County one of my counties is twenty four
thousand seven hundred eighty three
dollars after hearing the impact in
reviewing this tax season are you having
any do you have a different view at all
on these claims of what you originally
said sir
well we're monitoring it carefully I
mean I would I would comment that there
are a lot of people with salt deductions
that do have AMT relief I do think it
does hit the high end of taxpayers
significantly but we are we are
monitoring the impact on these economies
and watching it carefully thank you sir
in the remaining time I can quickly ask
you an Iran question last November the
full set of sanctions waived under the
2015 nuclear deal with Iran came back
into effect what impact you see these
newly imposed sanctions having and where
do you see issues with compliance I see
these new sanctions being very impactful
they are having the impact that we want
which is absolutely limiting the amount
of money that's going to Iran that's
used for terrorist activities it's used
for military purposes and we were very
pleased with the progress and the
enforcement of the sanctions so it's
something where we're monitoring very
carefully thank you very much for your
time sir thank you I yield to the
gentleman from Tennessee mr. Kozlov is
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair for convening this
morning's hearing and mr. secretary
thank you for coming back this morning
back in November ahead of the g20 summit
you released a statement regarding the
u.s. Mexico Canada trade agreement and I
appreciate you doing that two questions
as you know Congress is faced with with
passing or not passing the us-mexico
canada trade agreement two questions can
you address what happens to the economy
if in fact we do pass the USMC a second
question can you address the effects on
the economy if we don't
ask the USMC a sure well I am hopeful
that Congress takes this up soon I know
ambassador light Heiser has had
productive discussions with the speaker
on this because I think it has a very
important
you
just trading partners this has a lot of
support from the the governor's has a
lot of bipartisan support from business
so the impact is is quite significant
and I am pleased that we've reached an
agreement with Canada and Mexico on
steel and aluminum terrorists which
again is another reason to move forward
with the agreement quickly and what
would be the effect on the economy if we
don't pass the us-mexico candidate it
could be quite significant in the other
direction depending what happens whether
we stick with the existing NAFTA deal or
whether we terminated the NAFTA deal so
you know very very positive economic to
move forward on it so I'm encouraged and
hopefully the house will take it up soon
thank you
is it relates to Cecil the current
expected credit laws I've talked to a
number of I'm concerned with community
banks especially in my area which is
West Tennessee we have some really good
strong community banks who are concerned
about the effects that that the Cecil
implementation would have one on them
and their ability to lend money if you
or anybody in Treasury or any regulators
conducted a study to assess the
potential impacts to banks and
especially to community banks if Cecil
is in fact implement implemented or
those standards are implemented in the
next year or so
so I share some of your concerns we've
had discussions at the eff sock over
this we've had discussions with the Fed
and other regulators about delaying the
impact on it on trust testing and other
things so I think the regulator's are
understand this issue they're trying to
look at it carefully it is an accounting
provision so it's it's something where
we are focused on and we hope that it
the transition will alleviate some of
the concerns that you're you've
addressed but this is an issue we
continue to study I appreciate that
my district which is part of Memphis and
then West Tennessee has a large
component in fact it's the largest AG
district in the state of Tennessee I
hear from a lot of my farmers about
tariffs and the impacts of tariffs I'm
characterizing but generally the farmers
are supportive of the president they're
willing to endure short-term pain for
longer-term gain that's generally that's
not everybody but generally if you are a
member of Congress representing an
agricultural district what would you
tell farmers about tariffs and and and
what the potential impacts and and
hopefully the potential positive effects
that they may have well I can assure you
the president is very focused on the
agriculture community and the farmers
specifically we talked about it
almost weekly sonny Perdue participates
in our trade meetings and represents the
farmers in those meetings I think the
good news is as it relates to lifting
some of these tariffs with Mexico that
will help the farmers substantially in
terms of trade with Mexico and
reciprocal issues and it relates to
China if we can get a good deal it will
also be very good for the farmers I
think you know is unfortunately we were
on track for that and we've gone
backwards the president and secretary
Perdue are looking at various different
programs to make sure as we take in
terrorists we can use some of that money
to support the farmer so I can assure
you the president is very focused on
this Thank You mr. secretary and I yield
back my remaining time thank you the
gentleman from Utah mr. McAdams is
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair mr. secretary
thank you for coming back to the
committee this morning as you may know
Utah leads the nation with the highest
number of children per family on average
I myself have four kids so the cost of
household goods and children's items
specifically is a big concern in my
district a big concern for my
constituents as they map out their
household budgets every month so I
wanted to read to you a list of items
this administration is proposing to tax
in its trade dispute with China and I
know you refer to these as tariffs but
in reality you tonn's
Utah business leaders and Americans are
the ones paying these costs so I'll call
them what they are attacks I'm gonna
read a few of those of these items from
the u.s. TRS Federal Register notice on
proposed list for tariffs all of which
will potentially be taxed up to 25
percent baby diapers infant formula
children's Footwear infant nursery
monitor systems strollers high chairs
and bouncers baby carriages and child
safety seats and these are just some of
the items that are related to babies and
infants it's by no means an exhaustive
list because the list also includes all
forms of clothing and items that you all
that are also used by adults in fact you
have 76 pages of items that you want to
tax at a rate of 25% that's these items
right here in the Federal Register 20 76
pages of items that will receive a 25%
tax so mr. secretary I understand that
you and this administration want to
address China's unfair trade practices
and I support that but I don't I don't
think the strategy and rationale behind
this process has been properly explained
and I don't think you've properly
consulted Congress throughout the
process so I guess my question is what
do I tell mothers and fathers in my
district when the price of their baby
formula and diapers goes up what if they
can't afford those price increases so
they just go without buying diapers or
not buy a car seat for their kid what do
I tell them what do I tell them I'll let
you respond well first let me comment
I'd be I'd be more than happy to come up
and meet with you and a bunch of your
colleagues and explain in a smaller
setting our thoughts on this and and and
that you have a very valid point on
these issues so let me make a couple of
points first of all these are proposed
tariffs they are they are not in place
number two there will be an exception
process as part of this 301
we've already had too many productive
meetings with commerce and USTR and
others and three I can tell you I am
monitoring the situation very
carefully I was on the phone with the
CFO of Walmart which is obviously one of
the biggest sellers of the items yeah
that you've described to specifically
understand from Walmart what things they
can source from other areas and what
items they can't you know I would say we
haven't made any decisions yet but we
will be especially sensitive to the
consumer items and within the consumer
items I assure you that items that
particularly affect people on fixed
salaries and and have for kids and
others so there there is no decision
been made on any of these items and I
assure you we will monitor it very
carefully before we raise all these
items well and I would just say I think
I mean people are alarmed people are
seeing their costs go up already
in anticipation of these tariffs as the
administration set up the exclusion
process that you referred to for round
three on the China tariffs we are
working on the setting up the exclusion
process now I haven't seen the prices go
up I've been monitoring this very well
is there a plan for an exclusions
process around four yes there is and and
I would also just comment given the
depreciation of the Chinese currency a
big component of this is being paid for
by China because as the currency
depreciates our companies are being able
to buy things at lower prices but we are
very carefully monitoring the consumer
prices and that's something that I can
assure you the president will be very
focused on before we make any decisions
well I just want to make sure I want my
constituents to not be taxed to not feel
this pain in their monthly budgets as
they're trying to balance budgets put
food on the table provide for their kids
and their intra and their child's
children's safety when can we expect any
future announcement on the exclusion
process well I think you know the the
process of round four there won't be any
decision probably for another 30 or 45
days and we will have an exclusion
process built and ready if the president
decides to go forward with that thank
you I know that Representative Ron kind
has introduced legislation here in the
house that would require such a process
as well and I'm a co-sponsor of that
legislation
and for the sake of you know the peace
and assurances of the American people I
hope we'll get this process moving as
soon as possible thank you and I yield
back
the gentleman from Virginia mr. Rigell
moon is recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chairwoman and Thank You
mr. secretary I'm over here on the end
and Thank You mr. secretary for coming
back to committee this morning I know
the title this hearing is the state of
the international financial system but
before we get into that I wanted to
quickly discuss a tax issue
the IRS recently announced that
corporate alternative minimum tax
refunds received under the tax cuts and
Jobs Act will no longer be subject to
sequestration but AMT refunds received
by taxpayers in lieu of claiming bonus
depreciation under Section 168 will
remain subject to sequestration
taxpayers are no interest on AMT pre
payments and are counted
dollar-for-dollar against future
liabilities these pre payments operate
as interest-free loans to the government
that remain until the taxpayer incurs a
liability to which the AMT credit is
applied in many cases these pre payments
extend for decades the only way to
receive an AMT credit is to pay the tax
so these are not loopholes exploited by
American businesses but serve as a way
to reduce our tax layer built ax
liabilities should they owe money to our
favorite Uncle Sam I don't support a
policy that treats these taxpayers
differently particularly in the case
where the AMT credits represent pre
payments or overpayments of tax and
should not be subject to sequester and
sir can I get your commitment today that
you will look into the actions that the
IRS can and should take on behalf of
these companies on the AMT credit
specifically to remedy this situation
yes I can tell you I am familiar with it
it is a technical issue we're working
with OMB on trying to resolve it so
thank you thank you and I knew that was
probably a pretty quick answer so thank
you for that and and following up on tax
issues on March 5th of this year the
Department of Treasury released a policy
statement on the tax regulatory process
this policy statement established the
IRS is commitment to notice and comment
rulemaking the limited use of temporary
regulations in the proper role of
guidance documents one key assertion of
this policy statement says some
regulatory guidance is not intended to
affect taxpayer rights or obligations
independent from underlying statutes or
regulations and unlike statutes and
regulations sub-regulatory guidance does
not have the force and effect of law I
wholeheartedly agree with this statement
and what I love about a bureaucracy is
we actually have guidelines about
guidelines I think that's incredible so
but would you be willing to would you be
willing to officially adopt a specific
position as the chair of F sock I will
review that with F sock can take it up
with them sounds like a good idea thank
you very much
so the I think the entire administration
used to have the same view of guidance I
would argue that if this document is
good enough for the IRS it should be
equally appropriate for the F sock or
any federal regulatory body in the
United States and again it's just based
on my my business background with
regulations about regulations about
guidance I see my time is running a
little bit short but one final talk
topic I want to discuss the cyber
security and June of 27 Treasury issued
a report titled non-bank financial
FinTech and innovation in this report
Treasury state's regulatory
fragmentation overlap and duplication
however can lead to ineffective
regulatory oversight and inefficiencies
that are costly to the taxpayers
consumers and businesses by the way mr.
secretary I think you can see a theme in
my questioning today the report also
says that cyber security is addressed
among a broad group of federal and state
regulators to the financial making
information infrastructure committee FBI
I see when the predict Prudential
regulators were here last week this is
something I talked about I also know
that the FBI IC or the financial and
banking information infrastructure
committee is chaired by Treasury and
comprised of over 15 members from
additional regulators can you quickly
discuss how Treasury is working with the
numerous regulatory bodies to harmonize
cybersecurity regulations to protect
consumers without creating too
cumbersome a framework yes thank you it
is a major priority of mine we've added
additional resources to the Department
we've met with public and private
partnerships on this and we really have
two tasks one is harmonization across
the regulators we've reached
had a productive meeting with the bank
CEOs and the regulators on that and the
second is making sure we have better
coordination between our Intel our
technical people and and the private
sector to make sure that we're fully
prepared thank you very much I think
just in closing I would I would ask you
know as we go forward I would just hope
that we don't have any guidance come out
about sub-regulatory guidance which is
about the guidance that's not actually
not regulations thank you and I yield my
time thank you the gentlewoman from
Virginia mrs. Winston is recognized for
five minutes
thank you thank you madam chairman and
thank you mr. secretary for joining us
here today I'd like to talk a little bit
about your refusal to comply with a
lawful subpoena from the Ways and Means
Committee as you know section 60 103f 1
says that the secretary shall furnish
the Ways and Means Committee with any
return or return information specified
and requests you're aware of that right
okay and you're also aware that nowhere
in that section is is the chairman of
ways and means required to include a
reason legislative reason for the
request you're aware of that as well
I've read the language okay but in your
letter dated May 17th to chairman Neal
you rely on advice from the DOJ in
determining that the request lacks a
legitimate legislative purpose is that
correct that is correct okay now you
understand that that we're the
legislative branch so we make decisions
about legislating right I understand
that there are three branches of
government and they perform different
functions and you're the executive
branch right it is correct
which executes the laws you don't make
the love's right we make the laws now we
learned last night of a second opinion
which was written by the IRS chief
counsel's office are you aware of that
letter I became aware that memo when it
was we got an inquiry from the
Washington Post and it was just recently
published I'm not sure who the author of
that was but I've seen it in the
Washington Post okay so when did when
did the Washington Post inquire of you
about you I believe the day before
yesterday they called us up and we
confirmed that we that I and the
commissioner
not aware of that letter and had not
seen it but you have since that time
reviewed that memo actually haven't
reviewed it I looked at it literally on
the way up here someone handed me the
printed copy of it so I would not
describe that as I've reviewed it did
somebody make you aware that the memo
states that the law does not require
that the Ways and Means Committee
Finance chair or JCT chief of staff
include a reason or a purpose for the
request again I haven't again let me
just say the legal advice that we've
relied upon and again I understand
there's three branches of government and
when it comes to constitutional issues
there could be different interpretations
and that's why there's a third branch of
government to enjoy I'm sorry claiming
my time you you are aware you are at
least aware that the conclusion of that
memo directly contradicts the conclusion
that you're relying upon no I actually
don't believe that's the case that memo
I understand is addressing a different
issue and is not addressing the issue
that we in the Department of Justice
looked at but is again let me just say
this is not a letter that came to our
attention earlier in time who at IRS
would have made the decision not to run
this memo up the chain I have no idea
are you going to find that out we're
trying to find out who wrote the memo
where it came from when it was and why
it wasn't distributed yes all right have
you had any conversations with the
president at any time during your prior
to your confirmation or today or to
today about your desire or willingness
to to provide the president's tax
returns to Congress I've had no
conversations ever with the President or
anyone in the White House about
delivering the president's tax returns
to Congress I want to switch gears and
talk for a minute about Jamal khashoggi
ah the Washington Post columnist and
Virginia resident was brutally killed at
the Saudi Arabian consulate and it's
Istanbul the Saudi and Saudi government
has already acknowledged its role in the
killing of mr. khashoggi the CIA has
reportedly established with high cavett
confidence
that it was an assassination that was
ordered by Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman do you accept the intelligence
community's assessment of what happened
let me just first comment that it's
obviously a horrible situation that that
he was killed I can't comment
I obviously intelligence community's
assessment again what I was just like to
say is I have access to all of the
classified information it would be
inappropriate for me to make comments on
the CIA intelligence that my time madam
chair okay so let me let me back up a
little bit so you met with Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman less than three
weeks after the appearance of
disappearance of Miss Turkish og right I
did I was scheduled to speak there which
I cancelled but I did meet with him and
talk to him about terrorist financing
and I obviously there's there's a
picture that was tweeted out by the
either Kingdom on October 22nd is that
you in that picture with we also had
private conversations about the
Khashoggi investigation at that time
okay so you you were fine with appearing
publicly with with mohammed bin salam
come on I cancelled my public speech I
was in a meeting privately and there
were photographers and I thought it was
the appropriate thing to deliver a
message to him from the president woman
from Missouri Ms magner is recognized
for five minutes
I thank the chairwoman and secretary
minuchin thank you for the courtesy of
coming back today I'm especially pleased
it as a vice ranking member of financial
services and also the vice ranking
member of Foreign Affairs that we are
focusing on the state of the
international financial system here
today mr. secretary I was pleased to see
that the u.s. seized a North Korean
cargo ship earlier this month carrying
coal North Korea has also conducted
missile tests this month for the first
time in almost a year and a half with
missiles that appeared to resemble
Russian technology
as talks with the North Koreans stall in
North Korea demonstrates in its
increasing aggression what specific
measures can we expect to come from
Treasury sir well the president is
determined that we continue our efforts
to enforce of the UN sanctions and the
US sanctions against North Korea and
they've had a very important effect on
bringing the Chairman to the negotiating
table when we will continue to enforce
those sanctions especially in the
banking arena across multiple arenas yes
they've all been very effective
secretary the Obama administration
mistakenly believed that Burma was on
the path to reform and it lifted
sanctions and embraced eye-fi investment
given that Burma has continued to commit
atrocities against ethnic groups across
the country do you think IFIs
should continue engaging with Burma and
if so how can they help prompt a more
rights respecting environment I'm
concerned about the situation there we
will continue to have discussions with
the if' eyes and others and monitor this
situation so that there is the
appropriate outcome well and again I
just I hope that we will impose
additional sanctions that were lifted by
the Obama administration given the path
that has been taken visa vie the
atrocities that are happening against so
many different ethnic groups Burmese
civil society organizations have
expressed concerns with the IFC's
lending proposals in luxury development
projects infrastructure and agribusiness
given the country's corrupt business
environment and at lack of property
rights
how has the IFC used its position to
promote transparency and inclusive
economic development in Burma well let
me just say I share your concerns I know
our international department has been
having conversations and I expect to see
David Malpass very
and I will raise this specifically to
his attention Marie's anind that the IFC
and others should be doing this without
the appropriate conditions attached well
and I've been very pleased to send some
information along some questions if
you'll be having those discussions
please do thank you after issuing its
first US dollar denominated bond issue
issued this month the china-backed Asian
infrastructure investment bank or the a
IIb raised two point five billion
dollars and attracted orders of more
than 4.4 billion dollars the AIB has
said that the funds will be used to
invest in infrastructure projects across
Asia where the a III B is a major
financier of belt and road projects what
are the World Bank IMF and Asian
Development Bank doing to support the
belt in road initiative well I can speak
for the the IMF and the World Bank and
they are both very focused on debt
transparency and making sure that China
follows rules of debt transparency that
are consistent with the Paris Club and
others and in making sure that if debt
is taken on by these countries that it
is sustainable and that they can afford
it and if there's proper financing for
infrastructure that's one thing but if
there's money that's designed to loan to
own that's inappropriate and how is the
u.s. ensuring that countries aren't
aren't becoming overly indebted to China
or entering predatory contracts well
those are conversations we have at the
g20 consistently and I think there are
there is a lot of support from all of
our allies on this issue
thank you I'm about to run out of time
but I would like to forward some
information about Burma to you for your
further discussions thank you I yield
back madam chairman thank you the
gentleman from Connecticut mr. Himes is
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair and thank you mr.
secretary for being here I want to
revisit
Treasury's decision to delist rusul en+
and associated entities owned and
controlled at the time by russian
oligarch Oleg Deripaska I'm just to
remind you of the fact pattern here
Congress has informed on December 19th
literally the day we are breaking for
the holiday break that it is Treasury's
intention to delist these entities
nonetheless Congress acts On January
17th with strong veto-proof majority in
the house to disapprove of the delisting
the Senate acts as well but not with
veto-proof majorities and despite this
disapproval on the part of the United
States Congress on January 27th the
Treasury in fact D lists rusul and en
Plus as a result of the the deal that
was struck since then mr. dairy pastas
net worth and as much as I can calculate
it has risen by two billion dollars
largely as a result of the doubling of
the share price of vn+ and his remaining
stake that's what we can see visibly
Lord barker of battle who engineered
this deal the executive chairman of en+
received a five million dollar bonus for
his success in engineering this deal
lured Barker a battle of course denied
access to classified information by the
British Parliament because of his ties
to Russia and what I worry about most is
what the leader of Russia of Vladimir
Putin says or sees Deripaska says I
don't separate myself from the Russian
state I have no other interest so
Vladimir Putin sees the Treasury Act in
contravention in the will of Congress to
deliver this remarkable gift to mr.
Deripaska a guy who associates himself
with Russian interest at a time that
we're really coming to understand the
full effect of the Russian interference
in our election we know what they're
doing in Syria we know what they're
doing around the world so mr. secretary
my question is and I got into the weeds
with you on this I know on in a
classified session I had the opportunity
to talk to over fact I understand the
process and the mechanics but I wonder
if you can tell me what American
interest was served what strategic
interest was served by the decision to
delist en+ and to massively increase mr.
dairy pastas net worth
well let me give you a brief answer now
and I'd be happy to follow up with you
first of all let me just say many people
in Treasury including myself and a large
group of career staff spent a long time
on this transaction and negotiating this
transaction first of all it was our
decision to put him on the sanctions
list despite what we knew this would do
to the aluminum markets we were pleased
with the negotiations we think that this
shows that sanctions work that not only
is this administration done more
sanctions on Russia than anybody
previously but mr. Treacher I just mean
to be rude but when you say they I've
heard you say that before that sanctions
work and I've heard you say on multiple
occasions at the point of sanctions is
to change behavior so please elaborate
on what you just said how in this case
did sanctions work how did mr. Deripaska
change his behavior Russia changes
behavior what how did they work in this
case well what we've done is we've
effectively separated him from the
company we've put in a compliance system
with US and European people on the board
which is unprecedented and as it relates
to strategic issues I would just also
comment there were many workers
throughout Europe this isn't just
workers in Russia and we think this is a
perfect example of where sanctions work
there was a change in behavior by the
company the company was delisted but I'm
sorry tell me what the change in
behavior on the part of the company was
the change in behavior is the company
has separated themselves from Deripaska
and has agreed to an unprecedented
compliance program with a board a
Russian company now controlled by a
Board of non-russians it's it's somewhat
unheard of well first of all they
haven't separated themselves the dairy
pasca continues to own a 45 percent
stake in the company and there's
questions about whether he continues to
control it and I understand you made us
feel some obligation to European workers
but my question really was what American
interest what American strategic
interest was served by this deal which
which had the effect undeniably of
massively enriching mr. Deripaska
again this was never about kind of
trying to make Deripaska as net worth go
up or down this was separating Deripaska
from the company his voting interest
went down to 35
% he has no management responsibilities
we have unprecedented visibility into
one of the largest Russian companies in
the second largest aluminum company in
the world this is why I'm just I
understand the mechanics sir
I'm having a hard time understanding
look and I and miss gaki came and spent
a lot of time with me I got the
mechanics I understand them I still do
not see what American interest was
served here and that's my question to
you I believe the American interests
were served in separating the company
but I'd be more than happy to talk to
you more about it thank you thank you
Thank You mr. secretary I yield back the
gentleman from Oklahoma mr. Lucas is
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair mr. secretary I
really only have one question and I
think it's a relatively simple question
I would open with an observation that
you're obviously a man of patience or
you wouldn't be here again today I
consider myself also to be a person of
patience might be a better way to
describe that and before I ask my
question just to observe that I have
been like the chairwoman and a handful
of other members a member of this
committee for a very very long time
and I view us in many ways like a
corporate board responsible to the
entities that owned the enterprise
responsible the customers responsible
for the success of the process so I come
at that from with my question in 2017
the Treasury's capital the Treasury
Department's capital markets made
recommendations related to the lack of
harmonization between CFTC and banking
regulators regarding initial
inter-affiliate margin as your well the
regulators have not yet decided to
implement your recommendation last week
I asked the heads of the banking
regulators if they intended to
prioritize implementing your
recommendation based on their answers
I'm now very concerned they may try to
make it a part of a much larger review
of the feds regulations one which could
literally drag out for years so this is
my concern and I've been raising it for
nearly five years but it remains
unaddressed do you agree that a fix on
inter-affiliate margin requirement
should be
priority and will you impress upon those
agencies of the importance of acting yes
and yes and thank you for acknowledging
my patience absolutely mr. secretary
because if we don't address this we will
drive resources and will drive business
out of this country a reflection I think
of the topic of this hearing and after
pursuing this for nearly five years I
would simply say when I chaired another
committee it took me two and a half
years to pass a farm bill that would
successfully pass a Republican House a
Democrat Senate and be signed by a
Democrat president I and my colleague
former colleague from Tennessee when it
came time to do what was necessary to
reauthorize the export-import bank
literally used an extraordinary
legislative process from 1910 to take it
away from the then chairman and over the
heads of an entire majority leadership
to get a piece of legislation all the
way to the President's desk to be signed
I just simply observe after five years
it's time and if the agencies can't
bring themselves to focus to address
this issue perhaps it's time to help
them I simply use you as the courier of
the message mr. secretary I appreciate
your responses yield back madam chair
thank you
the gentlewoman from Iowa ms acne is
recognized for five minutes
Thank You chairwoman waters and Thank
You Secretary Minuten for being here
again I appreciate it
I'd like to talk to you a little bit
about tariffs and trade I'm from Iowa so
of course we're being hit hard first of
all I appreciate the removal of the
section 232 tariffs on steel and
aluminum however those were put on by
your administration but thank you so
much for removing those but I want to
talk to you about the tariffs that were
just placed on Chinese goods this month
and the tariff is almost on 200 billion
dollars of imports and it was just
increased from 10% to 25% do you agree
with President Trump that China is
footing the bill for these tariffs I
agree that China is fitting most of the
bill for it yes so who's paying the
price for these well again when you look
at the tariffs there's probably three or
four different things that are going on
one is a change in the currency which
leads to a lower price for us that we
can buy things to its margins that are
being absorbed by companies in China and
three there may be in certain cases a
impact passed on to our consumer and
we're closely monitoring that and
that'll be part of the exception I
appreciate your bringing up that last
piece because major retailers like
Walmart have said they will raise prices
as a result of your administration's
tariffs do you understand how a tariff
operates and could you tell us a little
bit about that I'm not sure if you were
here when I mentioned earlier that I
just spoke to the CFO of Walmart we
speak on a regular basis so I'm
monitoring with them very carefully so
our tariffs attacks on imports tariffs
are a tariff on imports they are not a
tax their tariffs are a tax on imports
and they're paid for by the US companies
who import those Goods so do our
companies like Nike and Adidas and
Walmart who have said they're going to
pass on these prices to consumers would
you not consider that an increase on
costs on folks like mine in Iowa and
Americans across this country well what
I mentioned
and the reason why I spoke to Walmart is
because obviously they have a lot of
these consumer issues the way the
tariffs were designed was the last
tranche was really the consumer issue we
are monitoring carefully there will be
some exceptions my expectation is a lot
of this business will be moved from
China to other places in the region so
that there will not be a cost so
reclaiming my time I'm not getting a
straight answer here do you agree that
American consumers will be paying more
as a result of these tariffs I don't
necessarily agree with that and that's
something we're monitoring very
carefully and we'll be issuing
exemptions so you disagree with all of
our key retailers in the country and
experts who understand that a tariff is
most likely passed on to consumers
because that's historically what happens
you disagree with that as a secretary of
the Treasury I just spoke to many of
these CEOs many of you disagree with
that that the tariffs will won't be
passed on to consumers in any way shape
or form again there may be a small
number of items where the tariffs may be
passed on and those are the things we
will specific so you agree that American
consumers will be paying more because
those tariffs but we've made no
decisions on that the last tranche is is
subject to the president's approval and
subject to exemptions I think it's the
importers that make the decisions on
that isn't that correct it's their
products that they're importing excuse
me if the decision is being made by the
the folks in our country who own the
companies who are importing the products
not necessarily you who's deciding what
price they're going to put out on their
product well again if we issue an
exemption it doesn't then there will be
no price increase and again most of
those companies are moving they're
claiming my time moving on can you tell
me what the average Iowan makes in a
year I can't tell you exactly but I
would guess it's can you tell me what
the average American family makes in a
year yeah it's it's it's between
depending upon whether you use the mean
or the median it's between 45 and 65
thousand yeah it's it's median is 60,000
closer to 79 thousand for the mean can
you tell me what cost these tariffs will
put on these American families
I don't expect there will be
significant costs on the American
families and that's something that we
are absolutely focused on have you done
research on this I have I as I said I've
just spoken to all the major companies
that provide consumer good so if you've
done research on this how come we
haven't seen this research I I haven't
seen it I don't think my colleagues have
seen it why hasn't that been passed on
to us to ensure that the constituents in
our district aren't paying the cost for
this well let me just comment the last
tranche is under investigation the
president has not yet made the decision
and the consumer products are by design
in the last tranche so will you commit
to providing us this research then again
at the appropriate time we will brief
Congress on what the economic impact is
of it yes okay well let's move on the
gentleman from Texas mr. Gooden is
recognized for five minutes
Thank You mr. secretary also wanted to
congratulate you because after today you
will hold the record for the longest
time served in a hearing by any
secretary of the Treasury so apologies
for not marking the occasion better
thank you I think it'll be five hours oh
very good well we're happy to have you I
was gonna ask more about these tax
returns my colleagues across the aisle
seem to be so obsessed with these tax
returns have has anyone in the
administration asked you to release tax
returns for members of Congress or
anyone else for political purposes no
they haven't in in both chairman Brady
when he ran the committee and now
chairman Grassley have not asked for
those returns which they would have the
right to ask for subject to
constitutional protections and I've also
heard that it's important for the Ways
and Means Committee and others in
Congress to determine whether or not the
IRS is actually auditing our president
and vice president is there any reason
to think that the IRS isn't doing their
job with respect to audits we've offered
to brief the committee on the audit
process they haven't taken us up on that
but I don't see any reason why they need
access to actual returns
do you understand that the process of
the audit is is fair and going through
correctly you were asked earlier today
in today's Washington Post there's a
story about a
potential memo from the IRS do you make
your decisions based on what's on the
front page of the Washington Post or
confidential memos that you haven't seen
is that how you do business as the
Treasury very rarely I don't think I've
made a decision on that basis I would
also just comment the memo is marked
draft it was not a final memo but I
don't know how it got to the Washington
Post it would have been more interesting
if it had got to me or the Commissioner
to review well I want to thank you for
your work I want to thank you for
standing up for the American taxpayer I
don't believe that tax returns should be
used for political purposes and I
believe you share that Republicans
certainly share that when they were in
power in the house a few months ago and
I want to encourage you to continue
fighting for the American taxpayer and
thank you for your work I assure you
weaponizing the IRS is a major concern
of ours that affects all taxpayers in
both parties well I think if you're
looking for evidence that the US
Congress doesn't need tax returns of
American citizens you can look no
further than the House Financial
Services and Ways and Means Committee so
thank you I yield back
the gentlewoman from North Carolina mr.
Adams is recognized for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You
secretary minuchin for returning you
know you said you're patient I'm patient
too but I've got to tell you I'm losing
patience with the president do you know
how many times the President Trump has
publicly offered to release his tax
returns I do not well we should have
something on the screen he's personally
offered to give us a glimpse of his tax
returns at least twenty four times it
was scrolling on the screen it'll
probably be back up
it was April 19th 2011 in an interview
when he first said that he said that if
President Obama would release his birth
certificate then he'd released his tax
reforms but of course the President
Obama did do what he said he'd do and
the president did not do what he said
he'd do so do you think the American
people have a right to know what's in
those tax before no I don't presidents
are not required to and the American
public knew that he didn't release him
before they voted for him so that's
right I'm reclaiming my time now do you
know what the president's hiding you
repeat that I'm sorry you know what he's
hiding I mean he didn't when you might
see him certainly not not come I don't
think he's hiding anything but okay so
you don't know we don't know anything
about his tax rate all right so we've
heard a lot of excuses over the years
about why he could not release them he
said well it was under audit but once
they finished that he would release them
but an IRS Commission to confirm that an
ordinance not necessary for you to
release your tax returns are you aware
that yeah but that's the president's
decision and I'm not involved in the
president's decision right let me
reclaim my time I want to get through my
questions so are you familiar with
Congress's oversight authority yes I am
okay so it's found in the Constitution
and public laws and the House and Senate
rules and it does say that when the
request is made by the appropriate
offices that
release him are you aware of that I've
read the law I've also been advised of
the interpretation of the law and I
understand the constitutional issues all
right so why haven't you complied with
with Chairman Neal's request because I
think that would be unlawful as advised
by the Department of Justice and that's
why there's a third branch of government
that most likely we're aware of then let
me clean my time sir so are you aware
then that by denying this that you are
in direct violation of the law no
absolutely not
I have been advised I am not violating
the law I never would have done anything
that violated the law and quite the
contrary I've been advised to that had I
turned them over I would be violating
around once so are you alleging that
chairman Neal lacks a legislative
purpose and that is the basis for your
refusing his request well given that
this is now most likely going to
litigation I think my letters have been
quite clear and why we have denied the
request and that's all right okay thank
you very much
so are you intending to comply with the
request at all no I've made clear to him
a letter that it would be unlawful for
all right okay sir and we claim in my
time now have you told the IRS not to
respond to Chairman Neal's request the
IRS independently the Chairman
independently wrote a letter concurring
with yes can you give me yes or no have
you you repeat the question have you
told the IRS not to respond to the
request again I just said the IRS
independently wrote a letter okay let me
clean my time can you give me yes or no
I don't all right okay you might not you
you won't give me yes or no all right so
let me ask you first of all I did
I did a little research myself and I
know that you've done some work with
Goldman Sachs and in the investment
banking sector have you ever lost a
billion dollars I have never lost a
billion dollars would you enter into a
business relationship with someone who
had a track record of losing a billion
dollars it depends if they made 10
billion and lost a billion all right
okay then you'll move on would you
invest in a business venture that has
lost a billion dollars again if it made
10 billion let me clean my time real
quickly I do have some concerns about
the the opportunity zones I sent a
letter to you we haven't gotten a
response yet I hope that you will be
able to respond to to the questions that
I've asked in that letter are you gonna
do did you get the letter I I assure you
that I will check with my group this
afternoon we very much support the
opportunity zone so we will be very
reasonable right I hope that you'll
ensure that the program does not
accelerate disruptive Genta fication in
those designated sense attracts sir I
yield back thank you very much share
your concern thank you thank you I want
to acknowledge gentleman from Colorado
mr. Tipton is recognized for five
minutes
thank mr. chairman mr. secretary thank
you again for taking the time to be able
to be here with us today my home state
of Colorado is home to a lot of
institutions that play a very important
role for rural customers as part of the
Farm Credit System as you know despite
the fact that the Farm Credit bank
focuses on rural America they have deep
ties in the global financial system as
developments around brexit continued
unfold there is concern over possible
spillover effects for rural borrowers
could you help us understand what
Treasury is doing to mitigate
consequences that may arise out of
brexit both in your discussions with UK
counterparts and with your colleagues
and Brussels we've been very closely
involved in these discussions now for
close to the last two years I think you
know we're not primarily involved but we
have been having very close discussions
and I'm relieved there was an extension
and I just hope that the UK and the
Europeans take advantage of that so that
we don't get to the brink again with a
heart brexit what
could have very detrimental economic
impacts Thanks
want to be able to revisit a topic that
my colleague miss Wagner brought up in
regards to the Belton Road initiative
and then also to the Asian
infrastructure investment bank
what is Treasury doing to be able to
pressure Beijing so the Chinese do
respect some of the same standards and
principles that we are not allies uphold
in terms of financial transactions well
this is something that we are absolutely
unified in working with our allies on
it's a topic at the g7 and the g20 I'll
be going to Japan in the near future and
focusing on this issue the IMF and World
Bank are and I think there's a
consistent view that proper lending to
developing countries is appropriate in
appropriate lending is not and we have
concerns about that and there should be
full transparency they should play with
the rest of the rules as does everybody
else I'd agree with that and it's
obviously problematic you know when
we're talking about the Asian
infrastructure and investment bank seems
to be the go-to creditor right now for
nations that are in need do you think
that they ought to be able to have
better development standards through
that bank and are there tools we can use
to try and be able to force that
absolutely and that's something as I
said we're very focused on when we're
talking about the World Bank it's often
rewarded for turning out large loans at
middle-income countries including
billions each year to China itself
tougher environments do tend to get left
behind when we look at who they are
lending to even though the bank is
supposed to be able to prioritize them
how can we address Beijing's belton Road
initiative would as major ambitions
obviously in Africa and isn't and
shouldn't the World Bank be more
incentivized to be able to tackle some
of the challenging projects on the
continent well let me just say I
couldn't be more pleased that my Under
Secretary for International David
Malpass is now leading the World Bank
it's the first time in an awfully long
time that we had an untested
vote on this uncontested I think David
is very focused on reforms at the World
Bank and is very focused on these issues
that that you've talked about making
sure that the World Bank is lending to
countries that really need the money and
making sure that there are consistent
standards throughout the development
country so we look forward to his
progress on that thank you and before I
close I do want to be able to make
mention of your work related to the ia
is capital standards for insurers we've
got a hundred and fifty year old system
of state-based insurance regulation that
seems to work well for consumers and for
the market and there is concern that the
European Central Road will raise
insurance rates in my district are you
working to ensure that our system of
insurance regulation isn't governed by
foreign regulatory bodies I am and I
actually can just tell you I just gave a
speech to the large insurance group here
is my longest speech I've given yet on
this issue and we'll make sure you get a
copy of it great I appreciate that and I
yield back the gentleman from Illinois
mr. Garcia is recognized for five
minutes
Thank You mr. chairman good morning
secretary like to switch gears of
briefly and talk about the financial
stability Oversight Council last October
the financial stability Oversight
Council known as eff sac which you chair
remove systemically important financial
institutions also known as cities
designation from Prudential meaning that
no non-bank financial institutions are
currently designated as cities do you
think it's appropriate that Prudential
which New York universities rates which
New York universities rates as the third
most systemically risky institution in
the u.s. now has as its chief regulator
the New Jersey Department of Banking and
Insurance
I we absolutely support the state-based
regulatory system and at F sake as you
said we've we've moved to a different
system of risk-based management so F
Zack then announced in March that it
would no longer designate non banks as
cities and that going forward non banks
would need to demonstrate a high quote
likelihood of distress and the quote
before being more closely scrutinized a
very high bar that non banks would
likely fail to meet under until their
impending collapse last week former Fed
chairs Ben Bernanke and Janet Yellen
joined former Treasury secretary Jack
Lew and Tim Geithner in criticizing this
move by EPSA warning that it would be
quote neuter the designation authority
writing of their experiences at the helm
during the financial crisis the for
regular regulators noted that the
failure of non-bank financial companies
was central to the propagation of risk
from the financial system to the US
economy international finance markets
and the global economy as a whole during
the crisis what do you make of this
criticism isn't it true that F sock just
made it harder to protect against risks
taken by non banks well first let me say
I think it's good that we have a system
where people can put in comments on
proposed regulations actually spoke to
secretary Lew about his letter they have
a different view on regulatory issues
it's a different time but I don't like
their letters will look at other other
letters before we put in final rules and
their view stem from the experience of
the meltdown that we experienced in 2008
would you please explain what recourse F
thought would have in a scenario like we
saw in 2008 when AIG for example greatly
expanded its sales of credit default
swaps becoming a major contributor to
the financial crisis
again because of the way we're looking
at it we would have picked up a AIG in
there risk associated with credit
default swaps the risk was primarily and
the holding company and not in the
insurance companies which were regulated
and that's the type of activity under
our new rules that we would indeed pick
up mr. secretary last week the Federal
Reserve released its financial stability
report and found that leveraged lending
has grown and that protections that
shield lenders from default and those
loans have eroded in light of the stern
warnings like these why has f sock only
convened on one occasion this year
actually f sock and specifically the
private working group the president's
private working group which is also
associated on this issue
you
not particularly concerned at the moment
we are monitoring very very carefully to
make sure this doesn't become an issue
so you're not very concerned about a
change in the economy and a potential
recession looming no I think in the near
future the chance of a recession is
quite low I think the credit quality is
extremely good in the case of leveraged
lending most of it has moved outside of
the banking business into non-bank areas
and in areas that don't have insured
deposits and we take great comfort in
that thank you i'm secretary i yield
back my time
about mr. chair the gentleman from
Arkansas mr. Hill is recognized for five
minutes
thank the chair mr. secretary welcome
back to the committee we never get tired
of our Treasury Secretary visiting House
Financial Services I want to raise an
issue first on Puerto Rico and the
Virgin Islands congressman Duffy and I
wrote you a letter last November 30th
about challenges and getting the
appropriated funds by Congress out into
the contracted private sector both in
the Virgin Islands in Puerto Rico
obviously both the territories have a
huge cash flow problem
so we appropriate money here we give
that money to HUD or to FEMA that's
approved by OMB and fully in compliance
with Congress's wishes and then it's
allocated for projects in Puerto Rico or
the Virgin Islands but they have no
money to pay the contractors so while
I'm not suggesting that we should have a
line of credit to Puerto Rico there has
to be a way within OMB and Treasury with
you as our chief financial officer of
the country of having that money flow
because I've got subcontractors in
Puerto Rico that live in my district
that haven't been paid in over a year
it's just an Accounts Payable the work
has been done it's met standards Puerto
Rico commissioned to do it but Puerto
Rico has no money to pay the contractors
and yet we have appropriated funds at
FEMA to pay those services so this is a
puzzle
I got an answer back in February from
your office which was a non-answer
saying that we will contact other
federal agencies for input and
investigate the issue of barriers to
timely payment and so today I won't
debate whether that was a non-answer or
not but I'd like to get your personal
commitment that you'll help congressman
Duffy and I engage with FEMA and drive a
outcome on this where funds can flow to
the territories I'd be happy to do that
I actually spoke to the governor of
Puerto Rico yesterday we're very focused
on opportunity zones there we actually
are within Treasury very involved in the
finances of Puerto Rico we actually
negotiated a standby line in case Porto
Rico through effectively its bankruptcy
what you're referring to and I apologize
was a non-answer I acknowledge it's a
little bit of a form letter the issues
that you're focused on are issues of
FEMA and HUD I'd be happy to speak to
the secretaries in DHS and in HUD
secretary Carson I think it would be
helpful because I think that the sub
cabinet staff level we haven't made any
progress so I appreciate your attention
to that turning to North Korea and
sanctions on March 5th the United
Nations Security Council released a
report on sanctions compliance it said
financial sanctions remain some of the
most poorly implemented and actively
evaded measures of the sanctions regime
individuals and power to act as
extensions of financial institutions of
the DPRK operate in at least five
countries with seeming impunity and that
includes to say diplomats of the DPRK in
those countries and of course diplomats
have immunity when they're functioning
as diplomats in certain countries my
question to you is how can we work with
our UN sanctions regime and tighten
financial sanctions on influence
peddlers in China and in the diplomatic
corps across the the world with North
Korea
so my undersecretary for TFI she's
recently traveled abroad to specifically
talk about these
shus talked with financial institutions
were very focused on money transfer
items we're focused on people doing
money laundering we're working very
closely with the intelligence community
on declassifying certain information and
enhancing the UN sanctions with our
specific sanctions against people who
are trying to use the financial system
so I assure you were on top of that
thank you I was pleased to see in the
Wall Street Journal day that additional
sanctions are being proposed for
Venezuela and I congratulate the
president and our UN representative for
getting a UN Security Council resolution
on sanctions in North Korea with Russia
and China's approval so my question to
you is in our national security work is
there a possibility we could get a UN
Security Council resolution in a similar
way with Russia and China actually being
constructive on Venezuela I can't
comment on the outcome of a UN
resolution I can tell you I was
personally involved in the North Korea
situation and the Chinese were
particularly helpful in getting that
done I personally have had conversations
with the finance minister in Russia
about the situation in Venezuela I've
also had conversations with my
counterparts in China I believe that
secretary Pompeo has had similar
conversations so this is something we
are very focused on Thank You mr.
secretary yield back the gentleman from
Georgia mr. Loudermilk is recognized for
five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You mr.
secretary I want to continue on the the
conversation about F sock and Sippy
designation but before that I want to
congratulate you congratulate you on
making free trade advocates out of
people that just in recent history have
been totally opposed to free trade and
never found a tariff that they didn't
like and so that gives me confidence
from what I'm hearing by some on the
other side of the aisle that's in the
majority at this point it appears that
we have free trade advocates and which I
think will pave the way for us MCA to
get approved so congratulations on
achieving something I remember in the
previous administration many in the
other party were even opposed
the previous president trying to get
some free trade agreements because they
like the tariffs so I think we're making
headway and also the obsession of some
on this committee with the president's
tax returns is not new from the moment
that he was inaugurated there were some
on this committee beginning and began
immediately calling for the tax returns
so just so I also want to say this I'm
not expecting a particular answer from
you so if you give something different
than what I'm expecting I'm gonna let
you answer okay regarding f sock and the
the cific designation process hugely
supportive of it I think it's important
to relieve the regulations on especially
those non-bank entities in fact I'm
working on reintroducing a bill from
last Congress that actually passed the
committee on a stand and passed the
house nearly unanimously so this is a
bipartisan effort and the bill would
basically ensure that non banks such as
investment advisors and mutual funds are
not subject to the the bank centric
stress test a quick question do you
agree with that approach that they
should be not under the same stress test
as the banks yes generally I agree with
that okay and I appreciate that what are
the differences between the banks and
non-banks where it makes this makes it
where the stress tests are not
appropriate for non banks what are those
differences
well the biggest difference is that
banks have taxpayer insured deposits
that create risk for the government okay
and I appreciate I think if we can
continue in our efforts to reduce the
regulatory burden on a lot of our
industries and understand that even in
the financial services arena one size
does not fit all will do more to benefit
the cost to consumer than anything else
we're doing so another topic done what
address is and I appreciate the
administration starting to address
housing finance reform I do agree with
the FHFA director that Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac need to raise significant
capital but I strongly believe that we
should start
reforms in housing finance how much
housing finance reform can be done
administrative Lee I think a lot can be
done administrative Lee we're working on
that we're also working on a report for
the president but I would also encourage
there is an opportunity for Congress on
a bipartisan basis to make some
significant reforms these were not
entities that were intended to be under
government control forever and funded by
taxpayer money forever so I hope that
Congress would look at this with us but
if not we will do things administrative
Lee so is the administration willing to
work with Congress to make some
significant reforms absolutely I would
look forward to working with this
committee and others this is a priority
of ours
I'm also encouraged that several private
sector industries mortgage insurers and
reinsurers for example have a strong
interest in absorbing risk from the GSEs
does the administration plan to expand
the involvement of these types of crap'
private capital in the housing finance
system yes are our fundamental view is
that there should be risk capital in
front of the government's money and
whether that's a government guarantee on
securities or Treasury lines
fundamentally there should be private
risk capital that supports a liquid
thirty-year mortgage market and I
appreciate that and from my opinion
reforms is not just relieving debt and
walking away I don't think that changes
changes any behavior when you just
relieve that and you will reward an
agency for bad behavior so thank you I
look forward to working with you on
these reforms and appreciate you being
here thank you the gentleman from
Minnesota mr. Emmer is recognized for
five minutes
Thank You mr. chair good to see it mr.
secretary thank you I appreciate your
work to produce the report on non-bank
financials fin tech and innovation last
year as you may know after five months
the committee was able to get around to
creating a fin tech task force on which
I'm going to serve can you give us an
update on your work to implement some of
the
Changez and are there any specific
urgent recommendations you have for
Congress in this area well I just
participated in the FDIC hosted a
FinTech conference it was extremely well
received we're working with the
regulators on all these we appreciate
the work that you're doing and we look
forward to sitting down and prioritizing
what things you think you could get
through on a congressional basis thank
you Dad how was the communication
between other agencies like the CFTC SEC
and the OCC and is there anything we can
do to better facilitate communication to
reduce regulatory uncertainty in this
area yeah I would say now versus two
years ago the communication is excellent
between the people that run these
regulatory entities again whether it's
through the president's working group
when we convene whether it's informal
sessions on issues I have regular
conversations we have monthly calls so I
think the communication is excellent and
one of the things that all of the people
who run these agencies are trying to do
is make sure down through their agencies
the regulators that the message is sent
to make sure that they work together an
example I do cyber a very important
issue different regulators should have
cyber exams but there's no reason that
the OCC the FDIC and the Fed have to
conduct three separate exams at
different times we're trying to get them
to do that together just one of the many
examples right another report of the
Treasury covered community bank and
credit union relief I've been hearing
frequently from small community banks
particularly those that engage in
banking for Minnesota's agricultural
sector are you hearing from these
community institutions and there are
there any statutory changes you would
recommend to deliver more relief to keep
rural communities growing we're very
focused on the regulatory burden on
community banks as I've said before I
think in many cases these community
banks understand their customers they
know their customers they know how to
underwrite
that they are a very important part of
our economy so we want to make sure that
they are not struggling and overburdened
regulation and there shouldn't be a
one-size-fits-all community banks don't
need the same level of regulation as
trillion dollar global institutions
secretary minuchin I just want to thank
you for paying particular attention to
every financial institution or entity
within the financial services food chain
because as your last statement in your
testimony indicates they're all
important whether it's the Main Street
Main Street community bank or credit
union all the way up to some of the
largest banks in the world that are here
in the United States that service all
kinds of things here and around the
globe we need them all and we need to
make sure that people on the street get
access to the capital they need to grow
new opportunities that only benefit our
local communities but ultimately today's
small business obviously is tomorrow's
big business
thank you very with you thank you sir I
yield back the gentleman from Colorado
mr. Perlmutter is recognized for five
minutes
mr. secretary good morning just a couple
questions first you know obviously and
you probably had it a dozen times and
I'm just now coming into the to the
hearing room you know the tax returns
are something that we've been seeking
for a couple years now and have tried to
through the proper procedures you know
bring them to the floor based on the
fact that every other president has
released theirs it's been a traditional
it's just sort of a matter of course but
then we've run into this stone wall
which is how we perceive it and I
understand and I and I guess I didn't
hear your testimony earlier but you know
the fact is that you hadn't seen a memo
but there was some sort of draft
amendment was that right I was just
contacted by the wall street excuse me
the Washington Post two days ago we
heard it I just first saw it this
morning and the paper
yes it's some draft memo that never did
get to us
who drafted it I have no idea what we're
looking into that okay in your dealings
with the president has he asked you just
to hold the tax returns if not no I've
never had any conversations with the
President or anybody in the White House
about what we're doing with his tax
returns okay so this is all within the
Treasury that you're making certain
decisions and or not
Treasury IRS which is within the
Treasury and the Department of Justice
we have consulted DOJ which is
effectively our lawyers
how has the at least the tradition of
every other president releasing their
tax returns how has that played in your
decision-making
it hasn't played into it my decision at
all I think it's that that's an
independent decision of the president
the American public knew that he wasn't
releasing his tax returns prior for
voting for him and they made that
decision that to me is a personal
decision of his and the American public
I have nothing to do with that okay and
I guess from our perspective obviously
we think there's something that's being
withheld or covered up but until we
actually see it to you release it till a
court orders it we're not gonna know
it's gonna be all supposition on our
part and that's just the way it is so
I'm gonna change the subject because
really thank you know you and I were
adversarial sort of on the pasca or
however you say the guy's name I don't
want to do that I want to talk about
marijuana thank you
it's rare that I would say I would
prefer to talk about marijuana than
those other two subjects but I'm happy
mr. secretary and thank you obviously
FinCEN and the Treasury have been
willing to work with us as we've moved
this subject forward and I would advise
you sir that at this point we've had a
hearing we've now had a markup we've
passed the bill out of this committee
forty five to eleven I think are
something over forty five to fifteen
thirty four Democrats eleven Republicans
it's now going to
eventually get to the rules committee
and to the floor and we've included the
FinCEN guidance as part of the
legislation so I don't know if you're
familiar with how this thing is
proceeding but again the basis is to try
to get the cash off the streets it's a
for me it's a public safety kind of a
matter and I don't know if you all have
been talking about it or if you've been
following this at all I have been
following it and first of all I
appreciate what you're doing on this I
have before testified this is an issue
for Congress to decide we have a big
problem and the problem is there is a
federal law and there are state laws and
from our perspective at Treasury we are
caught in the middle of this both from
the standpoint of the IRS where we have
to build cash rooms to take in cash and
from the banking sector and I would
encourage Congress to address this issue
it's got to be resolved one way or
another but it is not in anybody's
interest to have this amount of cash on
the streets which obviously would just
end up in illicit hands and a bad part
of the economy and things that are
unsafe so I can tell you we're having an
interagency review on on your bill but
in one format or another I urge this is
an issue for Congress to address one way
or another and I want to thank recive I
want to thank you I want to thank the
Department and a number of your
regulators because you have been working
with us as we've moved this so long
we've made some modifications based on
suggestions and and we will continue to
press this forward I know it's going to
pass the house and then we'll see where
it goes from there and I thank you and I
yield back the gentleman from Illinois
mr. Foster's recognized for five minutes
Thank You mr. chair um I was wondering
you know raised the issue of the the
pending debt crisis the default the
potential default what's the best
estimate for when that may happen if we
continue on business as usual I haven't
given an exact date but I would say it's
late summer and I I share your concern
and I would urge Congress to raise the
debt ceiling as soon as
possible are you familiar with the
Treasury report on the macroeconomic
effects of the of the debt ceiling
brinksmanship I don't I don't think I
need the report to know the the impact
which would be quite significant were
you in finance at the time and during
the 2011 I let me just say I had a
meeting with the big four yesterday and
I raised the issue of the debt ceiling
with them and again I would urge
Congress to raise the debt ceiling we
should have a situation where when we
commit funds we commit that we have the
capacity to borrow so I have no issue
with Congress should have the ability to
control borrowing and have the control
of spending but these things should be
done at the same time I concur on that
the whole situation sort of analogous to
refusing to pay for a meal after you've
eaten it but but actually without
objection I'd like to enter into the
record the Treasury report entitled the
macroeconomic effects of debt ceiling
brinksmanship dated 2013 without
objection so ordered and I urge you to
have a look at it's just a few pages but
it really says you know it goes through
the drop in consumer confidence small
business optimism S&P 500 took a hit the
VIX spike corporate bond spreads
mortgage spreads it just was bad you
know household net worth you know the
wealth of American families you know
dropped by more than I think multiple
trillion dollars this was a big deal
when it happened and you know there's a
danger of a recurring so you know
yesterday I introduced a bill that would
you know just a clean repeal of the debt
limit so that we would actually use the
budget rather than the debt limit to to
limit spending and I'm not going to ask
you you know to to opine on a specific
thing I understand there isn't really a
consensus on the issue and I personally
remain committed to working in a
bipartisan manner there are bipartisan
there are proposals that were hammered
out in the bipartisan policy group
would give cover to a number of
Republican members who want to you know
sort of at least maintain some sort of
fig leaf things with these are proposals
that would defuse the issue basically
defang and so that although it would
technically still be there
as a threat it would just effectively
not be so unlikely to be triggered and
so I was wondering if you would consider
supporting proposals or maybe even
taking leadership and trying to hammer
out some sort of bipartisan permanent
fix so that what this thing doesn't come
up again and again I'd be pleased to
meet with a bipartisan group we'd also
be pleased to provide technical
assistance again in one format or
another the debt limit shouldn't be used
as hostage to other things it is it is
so I'm fine with keeping the debt limit
as long as we have a mechanism that we
kind of do these things simultaneously
so that you know there's some mechanism
where it would never be the limiting
factor that would cause us to default
well as you said so we don't end up you
use the example of you know you had the
meal I think it's more like we had the
meal we left the restaurant we don't
want to pay the credit card bill you
know and do up confidence that the
market will react appropriately or
there's a danger of overreacting if we
threatened to default on our debts I
have confidence that this Congress will
not let that occur from my meetings with
senior leadership everybody understands
this issue and I surely hope we never
get to the point late summer where we're
even contemplating these things so that
was one of the topics we talked about
yesterday
and I would hope for the benefit of the
American people we raise the debt limit
soon thank you I'm yield back the
gentlewoman from Michigan mr. LaVey is
recognized for five minutes
thank you so much secretary Minuten for
being here I'd like to ask you about the
announcement this past March that the
Treasury Department will allow companies
to offer employees and current retirees
a lump sum payment for their pensions
instead of paying out the lifetime
guarantee that employees expected in
Michigan the office of retirement
services lists about
to over 280,000 retiree employees that
participate in public employee pensions
that's a lot of people in this move by
your department will have a huge impact
on the retirement savings of my
residents in Michigan's 13th
congressional district do you believe
that lump sum retirement payments
shortchange our retirees as they would
get be getting far less than they would
have received over time with their
pensions the dream that we do have our
our legislative agenda that we're moving
forward on it was a very positive
meeting of a respectful sharing of ideas
and I think very impressive presentation
by our chairs we do believe that it's
important for the to follow the facts we
believe that no one is above the law
including the President of the United
States and we believe that the President
of the United States is engaged in a
cover-up in a cover-up and that makes
the nature
a board member of so let me again we'd
be more than happy to follow up with you
for clarity thank you so much your
department is also responsible for
implementing the Employee Retirement
Income Security Act correct are you
familiar with that before I continue
okay
which is designed to protect and
preserve pensions do you think cutting
benefits by twenty to thirty percent as
a threat to pensions I mean you can
answer that without actually referring
to the rule
well obviously the pension issue in this
country is a very serious issue and
particularly it's a serious issue with
the PBGC and taking over pensions I will
tell you as it relates to this rule
Treasury's role is purely mechanical and
that people apply to us for this we run
the tests and then determine whether it
fits the tests and then go to a vote we
don't we don't it's not a subjective
issue
well my residents are also really
concerned though secretary because with
a huge amounts of profit that
corporations are making off of less off
of these lump sum payments that you
should be aware of Michigan's Whirlpool
Corporation for example estimated that
these payments would cut 39 million off
of its pension obligation
gypte lump sum payments would be more
than happy to look into that and get
back to and as I said that the PBGC
issue and pension reform is a
significant issue thank you and I would
like to discuss one last issue I'm a
u.s. pension plans with assets and
Peruvian reform bonds many workers and
retirees in Michigan secretary have
pension plans that are invested in these
bonds and unfortunately the per vien
government has not paid the u.s.
investors the debts they owe they
negative which this negatively impacts
workers in Michigan in the 13
congressional district about 30,000
people are in danger of losing their big
portion of their retirement funds with
the government of Peru owing them over
34 million dollars are you aware of that
I am aware of it yes what actions in the
u.s. second and your department where
are you gonna be taken in in regards to
solving this again this this is not the
only situation where pensions by foreign
government debt there's other areas and
we assist the pensions although it's not
our obligation to enforce it but we do
assist in these areas well you know this
u.s. investors purchase these bonds in
good faith and expect the Peruvian
government would uphold their end of the
agreement and I hope you'll do something
about it I will be remiss as somebody
that truly believes in the rule of law
as somebody that has practiced law and
as an attorney I would revise you
secretary to get personal legal advice
because the cover-up by this
administration it goes beyond just
providing the taxes you can consult the
Department of Justice but you personally
making decisions not on the best part of
the American people but to cover up the
the occupant of the White House I think
you need to be very very clear about
what your role is and what your
responsibility is to the American people
this is goes beyond just providing taxes
right it goes about transparency and the
fact that no one is above the law so
secretary please seek out legal advice
personally what your obligations are
because the Department of Justice is not
protecting you it's protecting the
president the gentleman from New York
mr. Zeldin is recognized for five
minutes
thank you madam chair and
thank you to the secretary of Newton for
being here today one thing that comes up
in this committee a lot when we were
talking about effective policy is that a
one-size-fits-all approach usually
doesn't work this may sound like another
boring DC policy debate but my district
on Long Island imposing regulations
meant for large international
multibillion-dollar banks on a small
community lender or the same capital
standards meant for a massive
international insurance giant on a small
family-owned broker is not helpful this
subjective style of regulation that
isn't tailored to the size of a company
translates directly to less credit
higher premiums and less opportunity for
homeowners and businesses and
hardworking families that's why I want
to start off by saying I appreciate your
work at F sock to formalize an
activities based approach for addressing
systemic risk I commend you for moving
away from the arbitrary designation of
certain firms as risky which is what the
last administration did enthusiastically
and instead focusing on actually
protecting markets and consumers from
real financial risk by dropping the
questionable one-size-fits-all approach
mr. secretary last week your colleague
at the Financial Stability Board in its
current chairman governor rainy Quarles
received a letter from 42 bipartisan
senators regarding concerns about an
ongoing attempt by bureaucrats and
Brussels to export European insurance
regulations around the world and into
the United States
we then echoed those concerns in this
committee during last Thursday's hearing
the European model is another perfect
example of an arbitrary
one-size-fits-all approach that would
not work in our country where we have 50
different states with 50 different
markets that suit the needs of local
consumers I appreciate your commitment
to protecting US sovereignty and the
state-by-state system in any
negotiations where Treasury is taking
the lead the most important goal is to
ensure the US insurance regulatory
system is deemed outcome equivalent that
means our system and most importantly
our companies that are creating jobs in
the US can be competitive on a global
marketplace but not subject to European
standards that don't make sense for
American companies or consumers this is
a priority nationwide in my district for
the local brokers who are ensuring our
farmers or fishermen and our working
families what I really appreciate from
you today is an update on some of these
international negotiations and
you're doing the prioritize American
consumers how can we put America first
but also open up markets overseas for
American companies that want to be
competitive abroad so thank you on the
the international insurance issue I just
did give a significant speech last week
on this we'd be more than happy to get a
copy of it to you Team USA is what we
call the interagency group of the
regulator's working with the Europeans
are very much focused on defending the
US state-based regulatory system thank
you we are here in this committee have
an ongoing debate about how hardworking
Americans are going to have access to
the American Dream and how to keep our
booming economy growing so it can
continue to deliver opportunities for
prosperity to all we all have to work
together to keep our system competitive
in the global economy but always put the
needs of American consumers and
businesses first there are tremendous
opportunities for American companies
including companies in my district as we
look abroad for those opportunities all
throughout the entire world
on a personal note I want to say thank
you you staffed up quickly when you took
this position and incredibly there are a
lot of really high-quality people at the
highest levels of your agency and it's
been fantastic to work with
with all of them so I just want to thank
you for making them an open resource
because I'm confident not just as a New
Yorker not just a member of the House
Financial Services Committee but as a
member of Congress that I am able to go
to anyone on your team on any cause any
question that helps me represent my
constituents as effectively as possible
so thank you for bringing in the best of
the best to fill these important
positions thank you for the recognition
of our team because many people some of
which are here with me today have given
up very big careers to come and serve
the government and are proud of being
part of Treasury so thank you thank you
thank you madam chair and I yield back
the gentleman from Minnesota mr.
Phillips is recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair and greetings mr.
secretary I come from the great state of
Minnesota home to a lot of farmers and
particularly from the third district and
the district I represent home to a lot
of multinational corporations from
Cargill to Polaris and and a number in
between and as you can imagine I'm
hearing from all of them on a weekly
basis with concerns about trade policy
and and and others right now but but I
want to begin with just a quick question
for you as you reflect on your first two
years in your role is is there anything
as you look back that you might have
done differently or anything that from
an administration's perspective might
have done been done differently a
broadly I'd say no that we've been
incredibly busy across a large range of
issues so broadly I would say no we're
pleased anything done nothing they can
go home but I'm sure I'm sure there's
small things here and there that with
experience we may have changed quick
question about oh fak approximately how
many people work at OFAC with the
Treasury Department do you know that
number we have several hundred people in
OFAC okay and and how many dedicated to
Western Hemisphere and Cuba particularly
roughly do you know well the way we
manage these teams is they are not
necessarily we move the resources around
whether it's North Korea whether it's
Russia whether it's Iran we tend to move
all these resources so it's a team not
dedicated to certain regions okay as you
surely know farm income is down
substantially over 50% in the last four
years I'm curious you know why would we
not open up Cuba to agricultural trade
and help our farmers right now well the
number one reason we wouldn't do that
Cuba is probably the single biggest
problem with in Venezuela today they
effectively have a National Police there
the situation event as well is just
horrible I mean I convene these meetings
the economic situation this is a rich
country the people are starving and Cuba
is a major reason for that which I agree
so hopefully when Venezuela is resolved
is that is that a possibility we might
allow our farmers to sell product to
Cuba you know III would I would think
okay that if if Cuba changed their bad
activities that would be an incentive
for them and a possibility so again the
the reason why we have the current Cuba
policies is because of the way they're
behaving okay my next question is about
our China tariffs and Polaris as an
example of a corporation in my district
being significantly impacted probably a
hundred and fifty to two hundred million
dollars to the bottom line because of
our policy right now you know what do I
tell companies like Polaris and what is
the endgame you know how can I
communicate why this policy is in our
best interest and in their best interest
well first of all I speak to literally
probably a hundred different CEOs so I'd
be more than happy to speak to the CEO
of Polaris if its impact in them if you
get me their contact information I
actually find it interesting speaking to
people and I'd welcome it the president
has been very clear he wants fair trade
and we were we've made enormous progress
ambassador light Heiser and I have
literally spent the last six months
negotiating a detailed agreement that
you know would take up this whole book
I've said going word by word by word I
publicly said I thought we were close to
an agreement we were beginning to set up
a date for the two presidents meet and a
signing ceremony I think it would have
been the most the biggest change in
their economic relationship that we've
ever had would have been great for our
farmers for our companies for our
American workers and unfortunately China
has taking a big step backwards now
sometimes you got to go backwards before
you go forward so I'm still hopeful we
can get back to the table the two
presidents will most likely see each
other at the end of June I can tell you
the president is very focused on on
farmers the idea is not to have tariffs
the idea is for them to treat our
companies fairly my last question is
about our national debt and deficit I'm
gravely concerned I wish this
institution was as concerned as I am
would welcome your thoughts about
what you think this nation needs to do
relative to our fiscal policy and the
risks inherent in the current status quo
well as I said when we designed the
president's economic plan coming in the
number one issue is growth that we have
to grow our way out of this we can't cut
our way out of this I think the good
news is we've achieved this growth and
we're way on our way to sustainable
growth having said that we also have to
be conscious of expenses yesterday I met
with Mick Mulvaney and the big four and
trying to reach a appropriate to your
budget caps deal we're happy to do that
if the numbers are prudent I think that
the debt we have to be careful of the
debt to GDP ratios in the prior
administrations in the Obama
administration and prior to that the
debt has doubled some of that was a
result of costs in the Middle East some
of that was a result of fiscal policies
but I share your issue that right now
our debt is fine but we got to be
careful that it doesn't continue to grow
disproportionately to GDP so you share
my concern I do okay thank you
Thank You mr. secretary I yield back
gentleman from Massachusetts mr. Lynch
is recognized for five minutes
I'm thank you madam chair madam chair I
would you like to use my time for the
purpose of a question of order before
this committee madam chair this witness
the secretary has been requested by the
house to deliver to Congress
certain documents that are pertinent to
a legitimate inquiry before this
committee and my question is basically
where the statute says that the
secretary shall deliver such documents
and does not anticipate or embody any
consideration regarding discretion on
the part of the secretary would it be in
order before this committee
to hold the current witness the
secretary of the Treasury in contempt of
Congress
that's my inquiry and I would I would
love a response thank you very much mr.
Lynch the question that you have put
before this committee is one that we are
unable to address at this time we will
take your question to general counsel
and we will put it in writing and we
will seek an answer from him or her
about what our next step could or should
be given the way that you have described
what you think may be contempt based on
what the law says so we will we will
move with that as quickly as possible
if I might just add madam chair the the
tactic of this administration and the
strategy of this administration has been
to to circumvent the oversight
responsibilities of Congress and and to
basically negate the constitutional
power that we have as a body by in my
opinion unlawfully refusing to live a
pertinent to an active inquiry before
this committee and others and that for
us to continue to allow that delay to
occur without meaningful consequences
will [ __ ] our democracy and and be
contrary I think to the the Constitution
itself so I'm hoping that that council
can act expeditiously so that we can ask
we can actually respond to whether or
not the secretary is indeed conducting
his his job in in contempt of Congress
thank you very much mr. Lynch I think
everyone who has read the information
that's available to us about the
responsible
I beg you don't cry now the time had
ceased for us to have this colloquy but
we will take the information directly to
general counsel thank you you're gonna
yell back
the gentleman from California mr. Vargas
is recognized for five minutes
thank you very much madam chair of
before I yield to mr. cleaver I would
like to say the secretary that I did
read the story about your father and
Jeff Coons I have to say it was a
delightful story I've never met your
father but after reading about him he
must be a great guy
thank you I would just say for the
record he didn't buy it for himself he
bought it for our customer no it was
very clear and that it was very clear in
the article but just again just reading
about him and his successful career in
business and then his enthusiasm for art
was a very happy reading for me I just
want to say but I do want to yield to
mr. cleaver it's clear Thank You
secretary is just one short question
when you were here last I represent
Kansas City Missouri and the rural areas
around it about 120 miles away from from
the city I asked you about soybeans and
there had been a very large purchase
order your exact quote was with a very
large part of while we're negotiating
they've committed significant orders in
soybeans so I responded you know already
said yes already I was excited about it
and so I started sharing that
information to reporters and people back
home and my staff followed up the next
day and the next day when I raised the
question you talked to some of the
gentlemen behind you and we can find no
no such orders that have been made and
it put me in a really awkward situation
you know I mean I'm sure you've misspoke
but but something needs to be done I
think you need to acknowledge that you
misspoke exact comments here I'm not
trying I don't want to be nasty I just
I just want you to know you put me in an
awkward situation can I am I allowed to
respond to that I don't believe I
misspoke I apologize my staff didn't get
you the information we will share it
with you I will tell you that since the
recent actions of trade this is mr.
Borges his tab or have you exact I'm not
look I'm not I'll be exact quote quote
what you said I'm not trying to be mean
and nasty I just but when you tell me
that I made a mistake that's creating a
whole new environment that I don't want
to go into and I want you to do is just
acknowledge that you misspoke and that
you you're going to get to correct
information on and if you go see you did
misspeak are you back to mr. Vargas on I
don't this time I want to thank you I do
want to make sure that you have time to
respond to secretary few like this one
that well I just I apologize I wasn't
implying you made any mistake so we will
followup with you this afternoon to
clarify exactly what I said and get you
the information so apologies
thank you thank you reclaiming my time I
know that you've are you mr. secretary
again thank you for being here I know
that you've already been asked about
this but I have to ask again about
Chairman Neal's request I think it does
have a legitimate legislative purpose
believe that you may not have been aware
of the draft memo from the IRS but
certainly I wasn't and now it has come
out and it seems to be somewhat clear
that we do have the ability and and and
the right to have that information again
I want to follow up are you once again
going to take a look at it and lie to
this memo well I will take a look at the
man why had not seen it till this
morning we didn't receive it it was in
The Washington Post it was wrapped so
obviously we'll take a look at it I to
the extent it changes our analysis for
whatever reason we would recognize that
again I think this is a very important
issue and you know I would just say
we have tried to be responsive to
Congress on hundreds if not thousands of
requests for information on this one
request we've been advised that there
are different legal views and this is
why it will most likely go to the third
branch of government and if if the third
branch of government a pines on Congress
is right then we would obviously supply
the document our issue is we want to
make sure that that the IRS is not
weaponized for any party and as I said
we've been advised based upon
constitutional issues that it is not
legal for us to pursue it and we are
this has nothing to do with anything
else okay I I do hope you go and review
it again because I think this memo makes
it clear that we do have a right to this
information again my time is expired or
thanking again say hello to your father
the gentlewoman from Massachusetts MS
Presley is recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
a secretary munition for joining the
committee again here today I do believe
our diversity is our greater strength
and arguably the greatest contributor to
our economy mr. secretary do you believe
that representation matters in American
politics and imagery Sartre was the last
part of American politics and imagery do
you believe that representation matters
in American politics and imagery yes I'm
so glad we agree a few years ago
secretary Lew put out a call to the
American people soliciting feedback on
ways to modernize our nation's currency
on April 2016 or in April 2016 following
a longtime organizing efforts from
several grassroots organizations he
announced a currency redesigned overhaul
that would more accurately reflect the
diversity of our society the American
people understood the importance of
representation on the banknotes of the
world's most powerful economy
representation that acknowledged our
history and all those who have
contributed
mr. secretary yes you know do you
believe people other than white men have
greatly contributed to this country and
its history yes right after ten months
of soliciting and analyzing responses
secretary Lew announced that Harriet
Tubman would be featured on the front
of the new $20 bill as it stands
currently our currency does not reflect
the diversity of individuals that have
contributed to our great American
history he followed the announcement by
directing the Bureau of Engraving and
printing to accelerate plans for the
redesign so the final design concepts
would be unveiled in 2020 the 100-year
anniversary of the 19th amendment which
granted women the right to vote which we
celebrated yesterday as you know 2020 is
only one year away and since secretary
Lew's departure we have not heard
anything regarding the status of the
currency redesign will the redesign meet
the 2020 deadline yes or no so let me
comment that the primary reason we've
looked at redesigning the currency is
for counterfeiting issues based upon
this the $20 bill will now not come out
until 2028 the $10 bill in the $50 bill
will come out with new features
beforehand so the answer is it is my
responsibility now to focus on what is
the issue of counterfeiting and the
security features the ultimate decision
on the redesign will most likely be
another Secretary's down the road I'm
sorry I just want to be clear for the
for the record so you're not so yes or
no will you meet what was originally the
2020 redesign deadline yes or no again
to be clear the redesign that we are at
20 no we will meet the security feature
redesign in 2020 the imagery feature
will not be an issue that comes up until
most likely 2026 and I'm just wondering
if you could explain that to me because
after an exhaustive community process
where people who organized for quite
some time and you said you you do share
my my sentiments an opinion that our
currency should be more reflective of
the contributions and diversity of those
contributions and so why the delay no I
didn't say that the currency should be
really you said imagery
I said imagery not referring to okay so
do you believe do you support Harriet
Tubman being
20 dollar bill I've made no decision as
it relates to that and that decision
won't be made in as I said there was a
there was a national there was a
community process again it's a decision
of the secretary of the Treasury right
now my decision is focused on security
features well let me just you know say
this the occupant of the White House
Donald Trump said that the move to put
Harriet Tubman on the $20 bill was pure
political correctness and he in fact
suggested putting her on a $2 bill so do
you agree that nearly a year of
collecting response from across the
country can simply be reduced to
political correctness I think that right
now I am focused on the security
features of the US currency which is the
reserve currency save me my time so does
that mean you have no intention of
executing the redesign as planned by
your predecessor well that it that is
correct I have not made a decision to
execute on a redesign or haven't made a
decision but yes I have not made it can
you commit to submitting a currency
redesign timeline to this committee
again the currency timeline will be most
likely 2026 which even the most
optimistic scenarios is probably beyond
my term and do you believe that is it
your personal opinion then since you
won't offer it officially that our
currencies should reflect the diverse
representation of leaders that have
contributed to this country since you
agree it's been more than just white men
again I can't separate my personal
opinion on these issues from the issue
of the Treasury secretary what is your
position as the Treasury secretary again
my position is that I am focused on my
responsibility to deal with the security
features and a decision they dress that
and what about imagery what about the
representation again it's not a decision
that is likely to come until way past my
term even if I serve the second term for
the president so I am not focused on
that at the moment are you into a woman
from California miss Porter is
recognized for five minutes
hello mister murnian thank you for being
here in June 2017 the Treasury issued a
report on banking deregulation
suggesting that if Congress raised the
50 billion
threshold above which US banks have
stricter oversight that it ought to do
the same thing for foreign mega banks
and last month the Fed took this queue
and they massively deregulated foreign
mega banks and this was on a wish list
that that you had suggested would be an
improvement there's a lot to be
concerned about with this but the most
glaring is that now deutsche bank would
only have to file their living will once
every six years and that's the same
Deutsche Bank that had a surprise three
billion dollar quarterly loss based on
your oversight of Deutsche Bank which
led you to believe it was appropriate to
deregulate them how did Rachel mink
manage to lose three billion dollars I'm
not see it coming well I appreciate your
concerns let me just say what we're
focused on is the US subsidiary I
understand I understand could you could
you respond specifically to how did they
how the hell do you lose three million
dollars and not not see that coming well
I hate to say it there were a lot of
people that lost three billion dollars
and didn't see it coming on we don't
want to repeat that you would agree
surely don't I can tell you I am
familiar with some of their really bad
investments and I find it hard to
believe that they made them but yes it's
a staggering amount of money we would
agree on and Deutsche Bank has filled
its stress test in three of the last
four years was fine for a mirror trading
scandal involving laundering with
Russian oligarchs admitted to
participating in a LIBOR interest rate
scandal and violated US sanctions
against Iran Libya Syria and the Sudan
most recently director BAE it came to
light that Deutsche Bank had failed
excuse me had willfully decided to
ignore suspicious activity reports SARS
with regard to the president and his
son-in-law
why is Deutsche Bank what is your plan
to hold Deutsche Bank responsible for
failing to do appropriate oversight and
respond to the regulatory controls that
are in place with regard to SARS well
let me just say this our issue I did
read in the paper I am gonna have FinCEN
follow up and make sure that Joisey Bank
has anyone else
Tsar's policies that are on everyone so
I'm not aware of whether this is true or
not true but we will have FinCEN
follow-up I go back to our obligations
would you be willing to respond back to
this committee as to whether that did or
did not in fact occur I understand that
we can't comment publicly on czars but
we will follow back with the committee
to make sure that we have done a
compliance oversight and whatever the
result is we are comfortable with are
you planning to ask the German banking
authority to also do additional
oversight of Deutsche Bank especially
given that we now regulate them less
much less than we used to
well again the US entity we will
regulate considerably so the USA and
today with intermediary holding
companies we will be comfortable that
the US company doesn't jeopardize the
u.s. the US financial system in my
conversations with the Europeans yes I
will speak to them and make sure that
they are properly regulating the parent
and today and I know the Germans share
our concerns I wanted to ask you about f
Sox hedge fund working group I had a
conversation with mr. Powell about that
F Sox last annual reports in 2017 and
2018 included